انضم الينا من العاصمه السويسريه جنيف
وكيل وزاره الصحه السعوديه دكتور عبد الله
عسيري دكتور عبد الله حياك الله مع نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض استمعت لهذا الحديث
ويمكن يعني الكثير من الناس تداولوا هذا
هذا التصريح لمنظمه الصحه العالميه بان
هناك وباء قادم كان هناك تحذيرات ايضا حتى
من شخصيات سياسيه على سبيل المثال الرئيس
الامريكي في وقت سابق بانه يجب علينا
الاستعداد الوباء القادم هذه التحذيرات يا
دكتور كيف ممكن نتعامل معه على محمل الجد
وبان هناك وباء قادم فعلا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اولا
نبارك قناه العربيه على هذا الكم الهائل
من الجوائز المميزه
والحقيقه الكلام اللي ذكر في اجتماعات
جميع الامن الوطني الصحه العالميه يعني
ذكر مرارا وتكرارا قبل هذا المحفل وهو
حقيقه يواجهها البشر من بدء الخليقه ان
الانسان محاط باعداد كبيره جدا من
الكائنات اغلبها فيروسات قد تتسبب في
امراض معديه ومن اختي الى اخر تتسبب في
اوبئه ولكن نادرا ما تتحول هذه الاوبئه
الى الى جوائح ومثل الجوائح اللي شهدناها
في كوفيد اشياء تحصل مره او مرتين لكل مئه
عام لكن الملاحظه انه خلال العقود القليله
السابقه كان هناك تزايد في اعداد
الفيروسات والامراض التي قد تتحول الى
جوائح لاسباب كثيره ولكن هذا يضع العالم
امام مسؤوليا انه يكون مستعد يحصل لا احد
يعرف اذا كان متى يحصل ذلك ولا احد يعرف
جدته ولا يعني توقيت ولا مكانه يعني يعني
يا دكتور اليوم لو سمعنا مثلا مدير منظمه
الصحه العالميه او شخصيات سياسيه نافذه
وربما عندها معلومات يعني ليست متاحه مثلا
للجميع التعرف عليها
والحديث بان هناك وباء قادم استعد الوباء
القريبا يعني هل ناخذها على على محمل الجد
والصدق ام لا نعتمد على الابحاث على
دراسات على ما تقوله منظمات او وزارات
الصحه في البلدان المعنيه بهذه الاوبئه ان
انتشرت فيها اوبيا اصلا
يعني الموضوع يحتاج الى توازن يعني
الهدف ليس الذعر وليس وضع الناس في قلق
دائم الهدف وان المنظومات الصحيه
والحكوميه انها تكون على اهبه الاستعداد
انها تكون لديها انظمه رصد فعاله لديها
قدرات بشريه قادره على التعامل مع هذه
الامراض يعني تجربه كوفيد اظهرت انه يعني
لدينا قصور كبير جدا على مستوى العالم في
موضوع رصد الامراض المعديه لدينا قصور في
التعامل معها لدينا قصور في الموارد
البشريه الذين قصور في التمويل في اشياء
كثيره جدا يعني يستلزم ان تكون موجوده
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الاوبئه وتقليل
الخسائر البشريه والاثار الاقتصاديه
النجمه عنها علميا يا دكتور هل الجوائح
تعقبها اوبئه او جوائح اخرى في مده زمنيه
متقاربه
الاوبئه مستمره هي طبعا نقصد بالاوبئه هو
مجموعه من الاصابات بمرض معدي واحد في
مكان محدد ولكن يعني هذه الاوبئه في يعني
فترات متباعده تصل الى خمسين او ستين سنه
قد تتحول الى يعني مرض جديد يتسبب بجائحه
لكن لا يمكن التنبؤ بوقته ولا يمكن التنبؤ
بشده ولا نوع الفيروس او الجرثومه التي قد
تسبب مثل هذه الجوائح اشكرك من العاصمه
السويسريه وزاره الصحه السعوديه الدكتور
عبد الله عسيري شكرا يا دكتور
التقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات